[Music]
well Smith's who looks just like her
daddy for sure but Willow is getting
remarkably candid about a very difficult
time in her life when faint first struck
I honestly feel like I lost my sanity it
wasn't me it was after that hole with my
hair thing it was just so crazy and I
was just like plunged into this like
black hole you know I was like cutting
myself what we've watched now 17-year
old willow grow up she seemed to have it
all famous parents a hit single at 9
years old the opening act for Justin
Bieber but after the tour
willow hid her cutting secret cutting
yourself and we're on my wrist I mean
you can't even see it but like there's
still a little something there totally
lost my sanity if I'm over there will
confess he missed the signs his little
girl was hurting until she shaved her
head bald in the middle of her whip my
hair tool and I was like oh and I'm
looking at that girl oh my god
one night I was just like this is
actually psychotic and after that I just
stopped
willows confession is in Episode two of
read Table Talk but why is Jada being so
open with her family secrets well we
asked I'm hoping that it will give
people the freedom also in their lives
to find their truth and to have more
courage to live their truth
[Music]